en este caso la presidenta no es
responsable de la ejecución y
administración del presupuesto Porque
después de la Reforma del año 94 del año
94 quien tiene la responsabilidad el
deber El Deber El Deber jurídico O sea
que puede ser demandado si incumple ese
deber de administrar y ejecutar el
presupuesto de la nación Argentina es la
figura del jefe de gabinete curiosamente
en este juicio los jueces los jefes de
gabinete solo declararon como testigos Y
esto no significa que quiera decir que
ellos tiene responsabilidad alguna
porque a lo largo de todo el juicio
también se probó que ninguna de las
aseveraciones de las mentiras que dijo
que dijeron los fiscales Luciano y Mola
en su alegato histriónico eran ciertas a
punto tal que cuando les tocó replicar
cada uno de los hechos no de las
opiniones cada uno de los Hechos de los
documentos de las pericias de los
testimonios que se desarrollaron ante
todo el juicio no pudieron replicar nada
Es muy simple Se pueden mentir sobre
opiniones pero cuando se demuestran los
hechos que esto es mentira no pudieron
replicar absolutamente nada pero esta
condena
esta condena con Patriotas no es una
condena por las leyes de la Constitución
o por las leyes administrativas o por el
código penal Esta es una condena que
tiene su origen en un sistema que yo muy
casi ingenuamente diría en la que
aquella vez el tres de diciembre el dos
de diciembre del 2019 hablé de lofer
ahora últimamente también rescatado el
concepto de partido judicial tal vez por
una suerte de deformación juvenil muy
lectora muy deteriorizar muy de analizar
Y esto es mucho más simple Esto no es ni
lower ni partido judicial esto es un
estado paralelo y mafia mafia judicial y
la confirmación
de la existencia de un sistema para
Estatal de un sistema donde se decide
sobre la vida el patrimonio la libertad
del conjunto de los argentinos y que
está por afuera de los resultados
electorales
lo tuvimos precisamente
este fin de semana Ayer el presidente de
la República en una cadena nacional hizo
mención
algo que tomó
estado público Por así decirlo O tal vez
estado en las redes yo estaba en
calafate
estaba en calafate y comencé a recibir
mensajes acerca de un sitio de internet
en el cual
se publicaron los chats
de un conjunto de personajes sobre un
hecho que había tenido lugar el día 17
de octubre qué sé yo no sé son esas
casualidades de la vida esta fecha tan
histórica para nosotros bueno
esto era un un viaje en un avión privado
a la estancia de Joe Lewis el lago
escondido es el ciudadano británico
que tiene secuestrado el lago escondido
para todos los compatriotas pese a las
leyes vigentes que hay en materia de
posibilidades que los extranjeros tengan
tenencia o sean propietarios de tierras
en zonas limítrofes ya vamos a hablar
también de eso porque tiene que ver con
los protagonistas de los que viajaron Y
de lo que pasó en ese viaje
privados de un vuelo que partió creo que
de aeroparque No sé exactamente de dónde
cuatro jueces viajaron allí
Y por qué importa acá en esta causa
ahora lo van a ver
los cuatro jueces fueron maiques Juan
maguiques que es un juez de casación un
magistrado de casación puesto a dedo por
Mauricio macri en la casación nunca
concursó para ese cargo lo extrapolaron
de la casación nacional y lo trasladaron
y lo plantaron
en la casación nacional Juan Mari que
recuérdale el nombre el otro era Julián
hercolini
Julián arcolini es el juez que instruyó
esta causa maiques
maique es padre es el padre también del
fiscal maíques que instruyó también esta
causa de vialidad ven
un juez en lo penal económico shaderola
juez Federal también y otro casial si
uno mira es como que está todo el fuero
federal el fuero penal de comodoro pi
hercolini
shadorola penal económico casials
contencioso administrativo
faltaría la cámara en lo civil y
comercial pero ella dicen que ni
siquiera hace falta porque es una cara
una cámara que normalmente se la conoce
o la conocían en la jerga me acuerdo
como la cámara en lo comercial y Clarín
bien Además iban dos funcionarios de
Rodríguez larreta El jefe de gobierno de
la ciudad de Buenos Aires que era su
ministro de seguridad
Marcelo dalesandro a quien recuerdo muy
bien porque fue Marcelo de Alessandro el
que colocó las vallas en mi casa cuando
sucedieron los episodios después del
atentado me bañaron la casa él fue el
autor de eso además de ser el autor de
eso días posteriores al atentado contra
mi vida y su acciones de inteligencia
con la policía de la ciudad que sacaban
fotos a toda la gente que entraba y
salía y a la propia custodia del
edificio de juncal y Uruguay
es también claro por sus características
el que controla la seguridad o sea
vendedores ambulantes etcétera que van
por toda la ciudad recuerdan no la banda
de los vendedores ambulantes que
finalmente teníamos terminaron atentando
contra mi vida
y también lo acompañaba otro funcionario
el jefe de los fiscales
el jefe de los fiscales que es Juan
maiques hijo
de El otro maíz que es Carlos maiques
hermano del fiscal de la causa la
familia judicial en su máximo esplendor
son así Si uno puede ver en los juzgados
recorre los juzgados es el primo el
hermano el tío la sobrina el numero
bueno en el propio tribunal que me juzgó
a mí el camarista hornos que va a ser el
que voy a tener que apelarle esta
sentencia el camarista hornos es el tío
de la señora del presidente del tribunal
que me condenó O sea la esposa del
presidente del tribunal el de Liverpool
el del jugador del Liverpool bueno la
señora es la sobrina del camarista al
cual yo tengo que ir a pelar